عربيه الهويه
عالمي الاتجاه
اول ما تشتغل في مجال الدعايه والاعلان
2005 كنت ثانويه عامه تقريبا
كانت الناس بترحب بيا وتقول لي انه خلاص
ان الخطاط يعني راحت عليه وانه دلوقتي زمن
الكمبيوتر وكل حاجه بتتعمل
تكتب بالكمبيوتر يعني
فانا كده ما ليش دور يعني جيت متاخر
2007 دخلت قناه المجد واشتغلت فيها خطاط
بدات احتك بالمصممين واللي شغالين في
المجال الفن والميديا بشكل عام واكتشفت
الفجوه اللي ما بين المصممين والفنانين
والخط العربي او الخطاطين الفجوه هي ايه
انه مش عارفين القيم الجماليه اللي موجوده
في الحرب اللي تخليهم يستخدموه في اعمالهم
الفنيه
الشيء ده كان هو اللي شاغلني
فتره طويله جدا ازاي استخرج القيم
الجماليه دي وانقلها للناس ويبقى جزء من
تصميمهم واعملهم بدات ان انا ابحث ده وادي
ورش واتعلم مع ناس بنتناقش مع بعض طبعا
لما واحد بعلمه فبيسالني فبعرف بيفكر ازاي
وايه المعيار اللي بيخليه يشوف الحرف
ويقيمه وليه هو مش فاهمه
كنت دايما بحاول احبب الناس في الخط بس
عندي مشكله وتحدي مقابلني انا هقنعك ازاي
بحاجه او حبيبه فيها انت مش فاهمها
وبالتالي مش هتتسوق
الكاتب والناقد البريطاني بيقول
الامه العظيمه تكتب سيرتها في كتب ثلاثه
كتابه اعمالها وكتاب اقوالها واكتاب
فنونها اما الكتاب الاكبر بالثقه فهو بلا
ريب الكتاب الاخير كتاب الفنون نتفق انه
الفنون هي عنوان مشاعر الامه طيب اهم فن
يعبر عننا وهيمثلنا هو فن الخط العربي هو
ده الشيء اللي نملكه لو انت دخلت على
الانترنت وبحثت عن اي تصميم لاي دوله
هتشوف مثلا حاجه هندي فعليها الطابع اللي
بتمثل البلد بتاعها كتبت حاجه اسباني حاجه
برازيلي حاجه كوري هتلاقي كل بلد لها
هويتها في التصميم بتاعها لو كتبت تصميم
عربي هتلاقي تصميم مش هتلاقي عربي المشكله
هنا هتلاقي هويات كتيره مختلفه متنوعه
المشكله هنا فين بقى
المصمم لما بيحب يعمل تصميم بيعمل ايه
بيدخل يشوف المستوى التصميم في العالم وصل
لحد فين المشكله ان المعيار ده مش احنا
بنحدده يعني مش احنا اللي شاركنا في
المعيار السائد الحالي مع ان الطب ان
التصميم هو ابراز الثقافه بتاعه المجتمع
نفسه زمان الخط كان بيعبر بده استخدم في
العماره استخدم في الاواني والحياه
اليوميه وطبعا في كل شيء في الحياه
دلوقتي الزمن ده للاسف الوضع اتغير بينما
مشتتين ما بين ماضي ملكنا توقف وبين حاضر
مش ملكه
التصميم زمان كان بيمثل هويتنا في مصر وفي
الدول العربيه وده كان واضح جدا شفتوه في
الافلام والمسلسلات كان دايما في عنصر
الخط كان موجود بشكل قوي جدا
طيب الخطتين شافوا الخط ازاي واسسوه ازاي
هتلاقوا ان الخطط كان بينظر للحرف ده
كانسان لما بيحب يوصف الحروف في نفسها كان
بيتعامل معها كحاجه حيه ادميه لها نفس
المواصفات تعال نبص مثلا حرف الالف في وصف
الحرف او في الخطوط زمن الكلام ده من اكتر
من الف سنه من اول ما تاسست الخط حرف
الالف هو حرف قائم
مستقيم غير مائل الى استلقاء ولا انكباب
دي صفات انسان يعني هو مش بيتكلم عن حرف
هو بيتكلم عن حاجه بتوحي وبتدي ايحاء حرف
الباء زي البيت
بيحتوي بيلم الشمل حرف الفاء هنا هوت في
نفس صفه الاحتواء في راس كده فالخط دي راس
ودي رقبه مواصفات انسان حرف الجيم هي تاج
الحروف بكل الخطوط دايما هي اجمل حرف
الجيم يعني الجمال طيب كل دي ايحاءات
الحروف بتعملها من اول الالف حتى الياء في
كل نوع من انواع الخطوط هتلاقوا دايما ان
الحرف بيعبر عن شيء
لما جيت هنا
اعيد تصميم شعار نفسه الشعار القديم كان
بيعبر عن الفن فرسم الفرشتين عشان الرسم
رسم الفراشه عشان يعبر عن الفن رسم بقعه
اللون عشان يعبر عن الالوان لما حاولت ان
انا اعيد تصميم هذا الشعار فكرت انه ازاي
انه الحروف نفسها هي اللي تتكلم وهي اللي
تحل محل العناصر دي ده يعتبر تكريد تصميم
الشعار بالخط العربي بيعتبر فن تجريبي
فحاولت ان انا بالانسابيه الشكل نفسه فيه
الخط روح الخط العربي اللي هيروح هويتنا
حرف الميم في حركه وهو بيترسم هو مين وفي
نفس الوقت لو انت قربت اكتر هتلاقي في
حركه حيه يعني بتترسم قدامك
فرحه فيلم جديد نازل وثائقي بيعبر عن بنت
فلسطينيه بيحكي قصه معاناتها فانا حابب ان
انا اعبر عن الاسم انسب حاجه اعبر بها ايه
هل اجيب صوره بنت ولا الممثله نفسها قامت
بتدور ولا ارسم الكلمه على شكل بنت ولا
ايه بالضبط اصدق شيء ممكن اعبر به حاجه هو
الحبر نفسه افكت القلم تاثير الالم وتاثير
الحبر حتى الطرطشه بتاعه الحبر ناصر يا
جدعان الكتابه استخدمت في الاسم لتامر
نفسه
هنا في تلقائيه في عفويه في حاجه حيه
تجلي واضح من الاسم ان هو له علاقه بحاله
التجلي بتاعه الدرويش الحاله الصوفيه اللي
فيها استمراريه وفيها مدد
الحروف فيها تراقص يعني حاولت ان انا اخد
الايحاء اللي بيديني الشخص نفسه من المينا
اللي هو بيعملها في الحروف ايه هو الجيم
واللام
حرف الياء نفسه عاوز ان انا ادي احساس ما
لا نهايه ازاي احققها عملت الموجه اللي
بتنتهي للبدايه نفسها الموجه نفسها بتسحب
العين لبدايه الكلمه نفسها طيب كل دي
ايحاءات دي مش معاني مباشره
من اجمل التعريفات اللي اتقالت من اكتر من
الف سنه
هو تعريف طويل بينتهي به عن الحرف العربي
او الخط العربي يخيل اليك انه يتحرك وهو
ساكن
طيب
الحركه دي ممكن نشوفها هنا
عاوزين نفهم الموضوع اكتر ونرجع نشوف اصل
الخط العربي اتاسس ازاي الخط اتاسس هل هو
قواعد الخط ولا هو جماليات الخط يعني هل
هو حاجات جميله
ما لهاش تفسير فلسفي او معاني معينه وما
لهاش اسباب ولا لها اساس
من اجمل التعريفات
بتمسني جدا الخط هندسه روحانيه كتبت باله
جسمانيه
هندسه وروحانيه الهندسه ده الجانب اللي له
علاقه بالعقل بالمنطق حسابات رياضيه
بيخاطب الاسباب والامور المنطقيه والقواعد
اما الروحانيات هي الجانب الجمالي اللي في
احساس الاحساس الفني اللي الانسان اوردي
اصلا بيحتاجه الانسان بيبقى عاوز يشوف
حاجه جميله فالخط مبني على الشقين دول
زي الخط الكوفي على سبيل المثال وهو كله
حسابات رياضيه يتسم دايما الخط الكوفي او
الخط الهندسيه كلها بالزوايا بالانضباط
بالسكون بالسبات امور كلها هتتعلق بالمنطق
فانا عندي جزء من المنطق موجود الخطوط
اللينه كلها هناخد هندسيه وخطوط لينه فيها
تداخل حروف بتمر من تحت حروف وبتمر من فوق
حروف في حركه بتحصل في رشاقه وفي
ديناميكيه عاليه جدا
المعاني دي كلها بتجيلك لما انت بتشوف
الخط العربي الخط العربي بيدي رسائل لعقلك
البطن وده اللي بيعمله اي تصميم واي اعلان
التصميم والاعلان ما بيخاطبش عقلك الواعي
ما بيديكش رسائل المباشره بيدي لك ايحاءات
انت
بتحسها وبتقتنع بها من غير
اكلمك بشكل مباشر طيب
الحركه دي
الخط عندنا نوعين من الخطوط في خط اسمه خط
خامل ده خط كده مستقيم ما بيقولش حاجه وفي
خط فيه ايميل كده المايل ده بيدي لك احساس
انه هيسقط انه هيصعد لفوق الخط الخامس ما
بيقولش حاجه دايما الحروف العربيه كلها
بتنبط بالحياه فيها حركه فيها روح لما
حاولت ان انا ارسم كلمه ملاذ
هي المفروض لها علاقه بالبحر
فاقرب حاجه انا ممكن احاول ان انا اعبر
عنها وتدي ايحاء انه الالف واللام يكونوا
مختلفين واحده لفوق تانيه اقصر منها حركه
الامواج نفس الكلام انا عاوز اخطب الانسان
اللي هيتفرج على الشعار دوت ويشوف حرف
ازاي ويتخيل نفسه جواه فانت محاط انا
بحاول اسال الناس في الورش شايفين ايه
فيقولوا انا شايف ان في حاجه في النص شايف
عوامه شايف انسان قاعد مستجم شايف الموج
حواليه من كل مكان دي الحركه اللي بتنتج
من الحروف نفسها اللي اتصممت اصلا على نسب
نسب في الطول نسب من الرفيع والتخين
تفتكروا الخط عمل المعادله العبقريه دي
منين من اعظم النماذج اللي انا بعشقها جدا
خططت مشهور كتب كلمه انا بالنسبه لي
تعبير عن المعنى اعتقد ان دي اصدق طريقه
ممكن يعبر بها ملتفت لا يصل هي مقوله
مشهوره جدا مقوله صوفيه مشهوره جدا
وبتستخدم في اغلب المجالات
ملتفت لا يصل يعني هو المفروض ان الفاء
بتمشي بالشكل الطبيعي العادي هو عمل ايه
هو بص الناحيه التانيه عمل حركه الالتفات
بشكل دقيق جدا وما استخدمش اي عناصر خارج
الحروف نفسها ما استخدمش عنصر في سهم او
عنصر فيه شيء اخر احنا قلنا في الاول لان
الحرف الفاء في راس وليه رقبه فهنا انت
حاسس فعلا ان في شخص
التفت
وما مشيش بالطريق اللي هو المفروض بيمشي
فيه مركز فهدفه والمسار الطبيعي للحروف
العربيه من اليمين للشمال فده المسار
الطبيعي عكس المسار حتى اللام نفسها فالخط
العربي المفروض لما انتم عارفين ان هي
مدوره هنا مبتوره ودي اسمها في الخط حرف
مش مكتمل فهو من الحروف نفسها عبر عن معنى
الالتفات عبر عن معنى الانقطاع اللي هي
العقوبه يعني الشخص اللي هو مش هيركز وفي
نفس الوقت حرف لا في النص يخض يدي لفت
انتباهه دي عبقريه الخط العربي بحاول انقل
ده في شغل التصميم بشكل عام ازاي التصميم
يعبر عن ثقافتنا زي يكون
بيعبر عن البيئه نفسها
التصميم من قوته وبيكتسب حيويته من
التعبير عن البيئه نفسها وطريقه تفكير
الناس عبيا
كان منتج فكرت في معنى الاسم عبيا المفروض
ان هي في اللغه معنى الكبر والفخر
والاستعلاء عبيا هي في نفس الوقت اسم
الخيل بتاعه الملك عبد العزيز مؤسس
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هعبر عن الكلمه ازاي والتصميم نفسه هيعكس
التصميم العربي ازاي
حاولت في حرف العين ان هو العين دايما لها
نظره كده بحرف العين في الخط زي عين
الانسان ليه نظره
وبيبصص لفوق مش ماشيه على السطر حاولت انا
اعبر عن الاستعلاء ده بان هي ترتفع لفوق
شويه الحروف نفسها حروف عربيه طبعا شيء
مفروغ منه فده هويه عربيه ان واحد الفنيه
اللي تعبر عن المنتج نفسه منتج فخم هيخطب
فئه معينه من الناس
النقاط نفس الكلام لها اللمسه الفنيه
عاوزين نعبر عن البيئه بقى نفسها البيئه
السعوديه هنعبر عنها ازاي فالثقافه
النجديه من الحاجات السائده جدا في
المجتمع دلوقتي
ويفتشوا في التراث بتاعهم ويطلعوه علشان
يكون ده دراسهم شفنا البيوت النجديه شكلها
عامل ازاي جردناها طلعنا منها الرموز
والزخارف اللي احنا المفروض هنحتاجها في
التصميم نفس الكلام برضو الالوان اللي في
البيوت دي استخدمناها في لون الشعار نفسه
وفي لون المنتج فيما بعد
المنتج خرج في النهايه منتج عربي يعني
تحس ان هو
لو انت في نفس البيئه شبهك قريب منك
وبيمثل فعلا البيئه اللي انت عايش فيها
طب لو المنتج ده موجود في بلد تانيه مش
عربيه هتشوف منتج يحمل ثقافه معينه لو انت
اجنبي مثلا او حتى اجنبي شاف المنتج ده ده
مش من اللي هو متعود عليه وده اللي ما
بيبقى حتى عاوز يعمل تصميم عربي بس باسلوب
اجنبي ليه فيقول عشان خاطر هستهدف فئه
معينه طيب ما انت تبقى قريب من الناس
وتبقى جوه البيئه نفسها وتحجز ده في
تصميمك هيبقى اقرب للناس من حاجه غريبه
دخيله عليهم طب اصل انا هفضل للخارج وهبقى
في متواجد في دول اجنبيه بنفس الفكره انا
تواجدت فيها اجنبيه انا عاوز اتميز فيها
ابقى انا عنصر مميز عندهم وبالتالي انا
اكتسب قيمه بان انا مميز
يحمل الزخارف العربيه والهويه العربيه
وبالتالي انا شاركت بقى يعني انا شاركت
بتصميمي وبرؤيتي العالم متنوع في ثقافته
ربنا خلقنا مختلفين علشان نتنوع علشان
نكمل بعض كل امه بتشارك بفنها بتصميمها
بتعكس دوت احنا كامه عربيه هنشارك بايه
هنشارك بفننا اللي هو ابرز عنصر عندنا
اللي بيحمل الهويه بشكل كامل واحنا اللي
اسسناه هي الحروف العربيه فاحنا محتاجين
نشارك في الحوار العالمي اللي بيحصل في
الفنون بشكل عام لازم نتواجد على مسرح
التنوع ده يعني من مصلحه العالم نفسه ان
احنا نكون لينا بصمتنا ولينا تميزنا طيب
ايه هو معيار التصميم الناجح هل هو
التصميم الجميل يعني انا ادخل على النت
واشوف اجمل حاجه موجوده واعملها عشان انا
كده عملت تصميم الجميل التصميم الجميل هو
اللي بيستمد
عناصر من البيئه نفسها اللي بيستمد قوته
من الثقافه اللي احنا عشنا فيها الخط
العربي كان عبقري جدا زمان وكان منتشر
بشكل جبار في العالم كله كان يعني لو
بحثنا عن الخط العربي في المواقع
متخصصه هنلاقي ان الخط موجود في كل دول
العالم تقريبا يعني تقريبا ما فيش دوله في
العالم ما فيهاش بصمه لفن عربي اسلامي
فمشاركتنا احنا ده اللي بيدينا للاسف
طريقه التفكير دي توقفت حاليا تصميم
الناجح هو اللي بيستمد قوته من بيئته قوته
من هويته
لو بصينا حوالينا هنلاقي الخط
جميل حولنا في كل مكان خط العرض ده اكتر
من 1400 سنه
متطور وموجود يعني يجتاز اختبار الزمن
الفانون اللي بتندثر مع مرور الزمن الخط
عربي قعد اكتر من 1400 سنه
لو احنا اهتمينا بتراسنا وبثقافتنا هنكتشف
فن عظيم جدا الفن ده اتطور على مدار مئات
السنين
وافتكر ان ما فيش مانع ابدا انك دايما
تكون عربيه الهويه علامه الاتجاه شكرا
[تصفيق]